Hi, Josh Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什·克雷格和亚历克。
This is Mason coming at you from Kansas.
我是梅森，从堪萨斯来找你。
Last night I finished my first watching of How I Met Your Mother and it has impacted me deeper than anything.
昨晚我第一次看完《老爸老妈浪漫史》，它对我的​​影响比任何事情都更深。
I do love the finale.
我真的很喜欢结局。
I will say that a little over a year ago, a month after my 18th birthday, my family lost my father suddenly and I totally lost faith in everything.
我想说，一年多前，也就是我18岁生日一个月后，我的家人突然失去了我的父亲，我对一切都完全失去了信心。
and myself and the universe, my relationships, everything.
还有我自己和宇宙，我的人际关系，一切。
In December, I discovered your show during the darkest part of my life.
十二月，我在人生最黑暗的时期发现了你的节目。
And I can confidently say that since the beginning, since I've started to resonate with Ted and his character, your show has been the greatest tool to aid me in regaining faith in society of the universe, myself, everything.
我可以自信地说，从一开始，自从我开始与特德和他的角色产生共鸣，你的节目一直是帮助我重新获得对宇宙社会、我自己和一切的信心的最好工具。
I cannot thank you guys enough for the incredible impact your show has made on me just in the past six months and for the many, many, many years to come.
我非常感谢你们，你们的节目在过去六个月以及未来的许多年里对我产生了令人难以置信的影响。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I'm a low, won't be super city, let us see, permit me to tell you everything, book city.
我是一个低等城市，不会成为超级城市，让我们看看，请允许我告诉你一切，书城。
Welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother, I'm Josh Radner, I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas, hey Craig.
欢迎收看《我们如何造就你的母亲》的另一集，我是乔什·拉德纳，我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里，嘿克雷格。
Hey Josh, my God.
嘿乔希，我的上帝。
I like it just making us cry at the start of every episode now, that's what's happening.
我喜欢现在每集开头都让我们哭泣，这就是正在发生的事情。
Look, there's a lot of great sitcoms out there that bring a lot of joy to people.
瞧，有很多精彩的情景喜剧给人们带来了很多欢乐。
I just can't imagine if they solicit letters from viewers that many of them are hearing that kind of stuff.
我只是无法想象如果他们向观众征求来信，他们中的许多人都会听到这样的东西。
It's just extraordinary.
这真是非同寻常。
I don't even know, I need to lie down for five minutes.
我什至不知道，我需要躺五分钟。
Can I just, can we just take a break?
我可以，我们可以休息一下吗？
I mean, that's a perfect example of what we're talking about and what we've been talking about since day one on this show is like the secret soul medicine that's in this show where this show reaches people in dark times and hard times and gives them some sort of, I don't know, like will to go on, it restores faith in people, in the world, society, like he said, we're just bold over, thank you so much for sharing that, we're so sorry for your loss.
我的意思是，这是我们正在谈论的内容的一个完美例子，我们从这个节目第一天开始就一直在谈论的内容就像这个节目中的秘密灵魂药物，这个节目在黑暗时期和困难时期接触到人们，给他们某种，我不知道，比如继续下去的意愿，它恢复了人们对世界、对社会的信心，就像他说的，我们只是勇敢地结束了，非常感谢你分享这一点，我们对你的损失感到非常抱歉。
So sorry for your loss, my God, that's really hard, thank you for sharing that with us.
非常抱歉你的损失，天哪，这真的很难，谢谢你与我们分享。
I mean, that's an honor that you would share that with us and open up, the show being there for you is like our dream come true as artists, and all we can say is thanks for like letting that in and then sharing that story with us.
我的意思是，您能与我们分享这一点并敞开心扉，这是一种荣幸，为您举办的演出就像我们作为艺术家的梦想成真一样，我们所能说的就是感谢您愿意让这一点进来，然后与我们分享这个故事。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, thank you.
是的，谢谢。
So before we dive into this week's episode, which is episode eight, season three, it's called spoiler alert.
因此，在我们深入了解本周的剧集（第三季第八集）之前，我们将其称为剧透警报。
It was written by help me out.
这是帮我写的。
Stephen Lloyd.
史蒂芬·劳埃德.
Stephen Lloyd, almost there door to door.
史蒂芬·劳埃德，几乎挨家挨户。
He's the third.
他是第三个。
It goes Chris Harris, Courtney Kang, Stephen Lloyd's about the longest third longest serving.
克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）、考特尼·康（Courtney Kang）和史蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd）的服役时间排在第三位。
How much?
多少？
He arrives slightly into season one.
他刚进入第一季。
Well, get to it, but a fantastic cameo at the end.
好吧，开始吧，但最后有一个很棒的客串。
He is in the episode, we'll get there.
他在剧集中，我们会到达那里。
Terrific.
了不起。
Alec, when did this episode air?
亚历克，这一集什么时候播出？
Originally on November 12th, 2007.
最初是2007年11月12日。
Man.
男人。
Well, before we get into this episode, which is a really fun episode, I think we need to talk about the big news of our personal lives, me and Craig's personal lives.
好吧，在我们开始这一集之前，这是一个非常有趣的集，我想我们需要谈谈我们个人生活的大新闻，我和克雷格的个人生活。
We are, if all goes well, the stars align.
如果一切顺利，我们就是星辰大海。
I'm so nervous to even say it out loud.
我很紧张，甚至不敢大声说出来。
Do we say it?
我们说吗？
I'm not sure we can say it, but I think we're too far in now.
我不确定我们是否可以这么说，但我认为我们现在已经太远了。
There's no correct.
没有正确的。
There's no turn back.
没有回头路了。
Craig Taliesin and I are having dinner in Brooklyn tonight.
克雷格·塔利森和我今晚将在布鲁克林共进晚餐。
Finally, after we, I realized Craig, I've gone through- It's a salad three months.
最后，在我们之后，我意识到克雷格，我已经经历了——三个月的沙拉。
It's a salad three months.
这是三个月的沙拉。
I've gone through two assistants trying to schedule this meal for us.
我已经通过两名助理试图为我们安排这顿饭。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I think it broke Lola.
我想这让洛拉心碎了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yes, she's forgotten it.
是的，她忘记了。
She's gone.
她走了。
She could handle it.
她能应付得来。
bring in Sam, but we got it on the books in a couple hours.
请来萨姆，但几个小时后我们就将其记录在案了。
I should be sitting across from the actual.
我应该坐在现实的对面。
This ship is unsingable.
这艘船是不可歌唱的。
We're definitely having this dinner tonight.
今晚我们肯定要吃这顿晚餐。
What could possibly go wrong?
可能会出现什么问题？
Yeah, well, I am sick.
是的，好吧，我病了。
I am powering through.
我正在通电。
You are sick.
你病了。
They made me very nervous by telling me you're a little under it.
他们告诉我你有点紧张，这让我非常紧张。
Well, I started the antibiotics, but I said I'd be like, I'd be like sick Barney.
好吧，我开始服用抗生素，但我说我会像生病的巴尼一样。
I'd be like, you know, I'm not sick.
我会说，你知道，我没有生病。
You're not sick.
你没有病。
This is fucking happening, man.
这他妈的正在发生，伙计。
We're doing it.
我们正在做。
It's happening.
它正在发生。
We're doing it.
我们正在做。
Okay.
好的。
I went and saw Death of Salesman last night with my friend, it's terrific, great production.
昨晚我和朋友去看了《推销员之死》，非常棒，制作很棒。
Nathan Lane, Laurie Metcalfe.
内森·连恩，劳里·梅特卡夫。
What a cast, who should I run out?
多么好的演员阵容，我该跑掉谁呢？
Run into, in front of the theater, we were both waiting for our dates to show up.
碰巧在剧院前面，我们都在等待约会对象出现。
Then Roger Bart from...
然后罗杰巴特从...
Does your dad know about this?
你爸爸知道这件事吗？
I was meeting a friend of my friend, Oscar.
我正在见我朋友的一个朋友，奥斯卡。
But Roger Barte, who played the clerk at the end.
但是罗杰·巴特（Roger Barte）在最后扮演了店员。
I think his name is Curtis at the end.
我认为最后他的名字是柯蒂斯。
At the end.
在最后。
We're jumping way ahead to season 90s.
我们正在跳转到 90 年代的季节。
He's repeatedly seen throughout the ninth season, which is set all over the cross the weekend in a hotel.
他在第九季中多次出现，故事背景设定在整个周末的一家酒店里。
And he was a great sort of fixture of that season.
他是那个赛季的一名出色的球员。
That's cool.
这很酷。
It was great to see him.
很高兴见到他。
And I reminded him and he remembered exactly, do you remember the table read?
我提醒他，他记得很清楚，你还记得表格上写的吗？
He was late because security somehow didn't have his name.
他迟到了，因为保安不知道他的名字。
Do you remember this?
你还记得这个吗？
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
是啊是啊，没错。
And he remembered exactly what his entrance line was because he had one of the greatest entrances ever because there's like 45 people in that room.
他清楚地记得入口处的队伍是什么，因为他拥有有史以来最伟大的入口之一，因为那个房间里大约有 45 个人。
And if you're a guest star and you're late.
如果你是客串明星而你迟到了。
Oh, it's horrifying.
噢，太可怕了。
Yeah, I'm mortifying, yeah.
是的，我很羞愧，是的。
So he came in, he's like, he's sweating.
所以他进来了，他就像是，他出汗了。
And he said, I'm so sorry, security, obviously, wasn't familiar with my work.
他说，我很抱歉，保安显然不熟悉我的工作。
That's a good line.
这是一条很好的路线。
It's a great line.
这是一条很棒的线。
It diffused everything.
它扩散了一切。
But it was great to see him.
但很高兴见到他。
And you know, it's fun to be in New York.
你知道，在纽约很有趣。
I mean, like, if you're in New York or LA, you run into how I met your mother, players over.
我的意思是，如果你在纽约或洛杉矶，你会遇到我是如何认识你母亲的，球员们都在。
It's so cool.
太酷了。
It's such a vast array of people we have forgotten, like every now and again, it's like, oh yeah, that guy's a dispersant in the show.
我们忘记了如此之多的人，就像时不时地一样，就像，哦，是的，那个人是节目中的分散者。
It's cool, nine seasons is very, the gift of nine seasons is we got some people.
很酷，九个季节非常，九个季节的礼物是我们得到了一些人。
We got some people in the show and some music on this show.
我们在节目中有一些人，还有一些音乐。
It's very, it's very cool.
这非常非常酷。
Doesn't happen anymore.
不会再发生了。
And also like, you guys would really plunder Broadway.
而且，你们真的会掠夺百老汇。
I mean, there were a lot of like great theater actors.
我的意思是，有很多伟大的戏剧演员。
With no greater example than Kristin Milliotti, who we saw in one song Broadway, and we were absolutely stealing Broadway.
没有比克里斯汀·米利奥蒂更好的例子了，我们在百老汇的一首歌中看到了她，我们绝对是在偷百老汇。
people left and right, including her.
左右的人，包括她。
Yeah, that's fantastic.
是的，那太棒了。
Great.
伟大的。
So this episode is really fun.
所以这一集真的很有趣。
Why don't you give us your little summary of what happens in this episode, Craig?
克雷格，你为什么不给我们简要介绍一下这一集发生的事情呢？
This is a good little sort of everyone's on the same train episode, right?
这是每个人都在同一列火车上的一个很好的小插曲，对吧？
We so much talk about the ABC thing.
我们经常谈论 ABC 的事情。
This is the sort of game of dominoes off of this one observation that when you love someone or you're infatuated with someone and you may not see a flaw of theirs, but once somebody gives you the gift slash curse of pointing that flaw out, you can't unsee it.
这是一种多米诺骨牌游戏，源于这样一个观察：当你爱某人或迷恋某人时，你可能看不到他们的缺点，但一旦有人给你礼物斜线诅咒指出缺点，你就无法忽视它。
And it's sort of like this opening dominoe falls where Ted is dating a new woman played by Lindsey Price.
这有点像多米诺骨牌开始倒下，泰德正在和林赛·普莱斯扮演的新女人约会。
He's great.
他很棒。
And Ted doesn't see her flaw.
特德看不到她的缺点。
And when it gets pointed out to him, it sort of destroys everything and results.
当有人向他指出这一点时，一切和结果都会被毁掉。
And again, these dominoes tipping over of everyone pointing out each others.
再次，这些多米诺骨牌倾倒了，每个人都互相指出对方。
Now, now everyone's returns on each other.
现在，现在大家都互相回报了。
He's had this woman and ruined for him, and then everyone starts calling each other out on their things, and that I didn't spoil it.
他拥有了这个女人并为他毁了，然后每个人都开始互相指责他们的事情，而我没有破坏它。
It's a little like the Spider-Man meme where everyone's pointing at each other.
这有点像蜘蛛侠模因，每个人都互相指指点点。
It's the Spider-Man.
这是蜘蛛侠。
This episode, it emplays the narrative structure of Spider-Man meme, which I don't think we even know at the time.
这一集，它强调了蜘蛛侠模因的叙事结构，我认为我们当时甚至不知道。
Yeah.
是的。
But also, it's another episode where it starts with a mystery, like we don't see the problem.
而且，这是另一集，它以一个谜开始，就像我们没有看到问题一样。
What is the thing?
到底是怎么回事？
Why is everyone snapping at her?
为什么大家都对她刮目相看？
She seems perfectly pleasant.
她看起来非常令人愉快。
I said that.
我这么说。
with my wife last night, it was like mini-mystery, right?
昨晚和我妻子在一起，这就像一个迷你谜团，对吧？
Right in the cold open, right at the beginning of the show, you're like, what is this?
就在寒冷的露天，就在演出开始时，你会想，这是什么？
There's something we are going on here.
我们这里有事要发生。
What do we, we're in Ted's shoes, we don't know what's wrong either.
我们该怎么办，我们站在特德的立场上，我们也不知道出了什么问题。
And the audience is very much, I mean, I always thought I was a portal, my character was a portal for the audience, but very much in this one, because the audience is just as confused as him, because you withhold, I mean, how many of your mother was like?
观众非常多，我的意思是，我一直以为我是一个门户，我的角色是观众的一个门户，但在这一个中非常多，因为观众和他一样困惑，因为你隐瞒，我的意思是，你的母亲有多少像？
It's legitimately confusing, and so good at withholding information, you know?
它确实令人困惑，而且很擅长隐瞒信息，你知道吗？
It's on a need-to-know basis.
这是建立在需要知道的基础上的。
It is, the whole beginning of the episode is maddening.
确实，这一集的整个开头都很令人抓狂。
And I kind of forgot what it was gonna be.
我有点忘了那会是什么。
I hadn't watched this one in years.
我已经很多年没看过这个了。
And I was like, what is her thing again?
我就想，她又是怎么回事？
And then I was like on the edge of my seat.
然后我就像坐在座位边上一样。
I was like, right, right.
我当时想，对，对。
She talks me too much.
她对我说太多了。
And we've abridged that in the cold open, but later we see the fullness of what she was really saying.
我们在冷场中删减了这一点，但后来我们看到了她真正所说的内容。
Have you ever had the experience of a dear friend dating someone that drove you bonkers?
你是否有过这样的经历：一位好朋友和一个让你发疯的人约会？
Or did you tell them or not tell them?
或者你告诉他们还是不告诉他们？
And what is your feeling about the ethics of telling someone that.
您对告诉别人这些的道德有何看法？
I mean, Ted is devastated when he finds out, right?
我的意思是，特德发现后很伤心，对吗？
Was he, was he, but I guess you could argue it either way.
是他吗，是他吗，但我想无论哪种方式你都可以争论。
Like are his friends doing him a service and saying, you'll see this eventually.
就像他的朋友为他提供服务并说，你最终会看到这一点。
So we're just going to fast forward here.
所以我们要快进到这里。
You're in the infatuation.
你正陷在痴情之中。
I like that idea of the goggles.
我喜欢护目镜的想法。
What does Marne say or the shoot?
马恩说了什么或拍摄了什么？
I'm forgetting.
我忘了。
You want to have sex goggles or whatever.
你想要性爱护目镜之类的东西。
Whatever it was like the idea of like, we're just going to take these things off here and just kind of tell you what's up.
不管它是什么样的想法，我们只是要把这些东西拿掉，然后告诉你发生了什么。
So I guess they think they're doing Ted a service, but I don't know, what do you think the ethics are?
所以我猜他们认为他们是在为特德提供服务，但我不知道，你认为道德是什么？
I mean, people should be allowed to discover it for themselves, and maybe they never will discover it, and then that's who you should marry, I guess, because you love them so much, and so for so in such an enduring way that you never see their flaw, or you embrace their flaw.
我的意思是，应该允许人们自己发现它，也许他们永远不会发现它，然后我想这就是你应该嫁给的人，因为你非常爱他们，所以以一种持久的方式爱他们，让你永远看不到他们的缺点，或者你拥抱他们的缺点。
I don't know, I found myself wondering about this philosophical question too.
我不知道，我发现自己也在想这个哲学问题。
You know, it's funny, someone, I don't want to get into specifics, but someone we both know, I broke up with a girlfriend.
你知道，这很有趣，有人，我不想透露细节，但我们都认识的人，我和女朋友分手了。
This is in like the later seasons and she was not on the show.
就像后来的几季一样，她没有出现在节目中。
She was like, no one, you know, but this person, this mutual friend of ours said, oh, good.
她说，没有人，你知道，但是这个人，我们共同的朋友说，哦，很好。
You don't want to be with her, right?
你不想和她在一起，对吗？
And she went home and her husband said, you can never say that to someone.
她回家后，她丈夫说，你永远不能对别人说这种话。
And she said, why is it?
她说，为什么呢？
What if they get back together?
如果他们复合怎么办？
Yeah.
是的。
And we got back together.
我们又复合了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
We got back together for about seven or eight months.
我们又复合了大约七八个月。
And I think she was pretty horrified.
我认为她非常害怕。
But wait, wait, wait, wait did in that moment where she said that your friend said that wasn't where the flaws pointed out Was it like good you can't be with her cuz barra or was the canner worms wasn't open?
但是等等，等等，等等，等等，在那一刻，她说你的朋友说这不是缺陷所在，你不能和她在一起是好事还是因为罐头蠕虫没有打开？
No She just thought it was she just more thought it wasn't a match.
不，她只是认为这是她只是更认为这不匹配。
She didn't like okay It wasn't like quite spoiler alert.
她不喜欢，好吧，这不像是剧透警报。
It wasn't this mechanism.
不是这个机制。
It wasn't not that but it was like a little tough You're walking a fine line here, Fred.
事实并非如此，但有点艰难，弗雷德，你在这里走得很好。
Yeah You're gonna tell me a dinner with the full story.
是的，你会在晚餐时告诉我完整的故事。
I can't wait for dinner now Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
我现在等不及吃晚饭了嗨，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the hyper-fixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的超固定播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I think it's one thing when you're casually dating someone.
我认为当你随意和某人约会时这是一回事。
It's another thing if there's like a ring has been presented.
如果有人赠送了戒指，那就是另一回事了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Hey, right, this is a very different question depending on where in the timeline we are.
嘿，对了，这是一个非常不同的问题，具体取决于我们在时间轴上的位置。
Because Ted has just met this woman.
因为特德刚刚认识这个女人。
And I guess you can sort of say it.
我想你可以这么说。
And to be fair, they were not telling him until he prided out of them.
公平地说，直到他因他们而感到自豪时，他们才告诉他。
And it's very funny, his buyer's remorse once he knows, like, why did you tell me?
很有趣的是，他的买家一旦知道就会后悔，比如，你为什么告诉我？
You know I didn't really want to know which to Marshall.
你知道我并不是真的想知道马歇尔是哪一个。
But also, I think if Barney or Robin or Lily, one of them thought this, he might have been able to brush it off.
而且，我认为，如果巴尼、罗宾或莉莉中的一个人这么想，他可能会不予理睬。
The uniformity of the opinion around this thing is so strong.
围绕这件事的意见非常一致。
It's like his four best friends in the world are like, she won't stop talking, this is unbearable.
就像他世界上最好的四个朋友一样，她不停地说，这让人难以忍受。
Yeah.
是的。
It must have been where do you guys come up with the, is it like the, the glass breaking or the mirror breaking?
你们一定是从哪里想到的，是玻璃破碎还是镜子破碎？
Yeah.
是的。
Just, just, just the idea of like you can't put it back together again.
只是，只是，就像你无法再把它重新组合在一起的想法。
Just that idea like it's something has, and illusion, as an illusion has shattered and you can't put it by, we're, we're looking for the perfect kind of device of that.
只是那种想法，就像它已经存在一样，还有幻觉，因为幻觉已经破碎，你不能把它放在一边，我们正在寻找一种完美的装置。
And I really like that, that sound effect and that's sort of the feeling of that's the moment.
我真的很喜欢那个声音效果，那就是那一刻的感觉。
There's no turning back.
没有回头路了。
Yeah.
是的。
You can't put that toothpaste back in the tube.
你不能把牙膏放回管子里。
Barney's metaphor was a car, right?
巴尼的比喻是一辆汽车，对吗？
It was you're driving, and there's a blind spot in the car.
是你在开车，车里有一个盲点。
There's just a blind spot towards this person, and it feels like a real thing.
只是对这个人有盲点，感觉就像是真人一样。
I definitely feel like it's real.
我绝对感觉这是真的。
I think another good hemiumism besides many mysteries is legitimately interesting, juicy debates.
我认为，除了许多谜团之外，另一个好的半解就是有趣、有趣的辩论。
This is a philosophical debate, right?
这是一场哲学辩论，对吗？
Totally.
完全。
Do you say the thing, when do you say the thing, when does it pass the point, when you can say the thing, what if you say the thing they break up and they go back together, all of this is an ethic, this is a study in ethics.
你说这个话吗，你什么时候说这个话，什么时候过了重点，什么时候你可以说这个话，如果你说这个话他们分手了然后他们又在一起了怎么办，这一切都是一个伦理，这是伦理学的研究。
It really, I don't know whether the university class on how I met your mother could do a juicy seminar in this one.
真的，我不知道关于我如何认识你母亲的大学课程是否可以在这方面举办一场有趣的研讨会。
Yeah.
是的。
And I love how everyone just turns on each other from just everyone's flaws.
我喜欢每个人都因为每个人的缺点而互相攻击。
And it becomes this study in acceptance versus honesty or saying something versus not saying something.
这就变成了接受与诚实、说某事与不说某事的研究。
It starts to, in fact, it's almost like this contagion.
事实上，它开始就像这种传染病。
It's almost like an outbreak story.
这几乎就像一个爆发的故事。
That's like slowly the idea of this glass breaking disease starts like infiltrating the group and just the way everyone turns on each other is really funny.
就像这种玻璃破碎疾病的想法慢慢地开始渗透到这个群体中，每个人互相攻击的方式真的很有趣。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It's a good gang episode.
这是一部很好的帮派剧。
Like the whole gang is- It is a good gang episode, everyone is in the same story.
就像整个帮派一样——这是一个很好的帮派情节，每个人都在同一个故事中。
Yeah.
是的。
Was that fun?
有趣吗？
Do you like an episode?
你喜欢一集吗？
Do you like acting in an episode like that where it's, well, it's great that it started with Ted.
你喜欢在这样的剧集中表演吗？嗯，很高兴由泰德开始。
It's great that Ted was the mystery.
特德是个谜，这真是太好了。
But then when everyone starts turning on each other, it's there was a good energy.
但当每个人开始互相攻击时，就会产生一种良好的能量。
It was very entertaining to watch.
观看起来非常有趣。
And the flashbacks kind of filling in the lore, as I say, like those were super fun.
正如我所说，闪回有点填补了传说，就像那些超级有趣一样。
Those were fun.
那些很有趣。
Did you, so I'm curious like writer's room, like that's a great writer's room prompt, like what's annoying about each of these people?
你是吗，所以我很好奇，就像作家的房间，就像这是一个很棒的作家房间提示，就像这些人中的每个人有什么令人讨厌的？
And I think you had established Marshall the singer, right?
我认为你已经让马歇尔成为歌手，对吗？
Yes, that felt very natural because we were really just calling out something that was already there.
是的，这感觉很自然，因为我们实际上只是在呼唤已经存在的东西。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
His singing was at least in season one was established like he was just by himself, kind of amusing himself, but it was funny to open it up, like he's actually doing it around them the whole time.
他的歌声至少在第一季就已经确定了，就像他一个人在唱歌，有点自娱自乐，但打开它很有趣，就像他实际上一直在他们身边做的那样。
I think Ted, like by season three, you guys were very much into Ted, the intellect, Ted, the kind of snooty, you know, as neat or whatever.
我认为泰德，就像第三季一样，你们非常喜欢泰德，泰德的智慧，泰德的那种傲慢，你知道，整洁或其他什么。
So I think you were leaning into that.
所以我认为你倾向于这一点。
You know what's so funny?
你知道什么这么好笑吗？
I was, I always felt a little bit, it's so weird cause I'm watching this shit, here, listen, this is a shout out to my mother-in-law.
我是，我总是感觉有点，这太奇怪了，因为我正在看这个狗屎，听着，这是对我岳母的喊叫。
My mother-in-law doesn't like swearing.
我婆婆不喜欢说脏话。
and whenever I say.
每当我说。
You hear her voice in your head?
你在脑海中听到她的声音吗？
Because you say.
因为你说。
I hear her, I hear her, she listens to this show.
我听到她的声音，我听到她的声音，她听这个节目。
Yeah.
是的。
And I hear her thinking, I wish you wouldn't.
我听到她在想，我希望你不要这样做。
She doesn't even sound like that.
她听起来根本不是那样的。
I wish you wouldn't.
我希望你不要。
Let's hate me that.
让我们讨厌我吧。
That's not what her voice sounds like.
她的声音听起来不是这样的。
Sorry, Vivian.
对不起，维维安。
Whenever I think about, whenever I would think about, or whenever I, you handed us the stuff, the TED as kind of intellectual snob, I knew it worked because it got huge laughs from, you know, the table reads and the crew.
每当我想到，每当我想到，或者每当我，你把东西交给我们，TED作为一种知识势利小人，我就知道它起作用了，因为它得到了桌子上的文字和工作人员的巨大笑声。
And I knew I was doing it well.
我知道我做得很好。
but there was a part of me that felt a little bit, and I think it was because when I had talked about this, but when I would recommend a book on Twitter, people would be like, oh, you're just like, Ted, like it may feel like I couldn't be my own self who's actually curious about philosophy and theology and literature and love that stuff.
但我心里有一点感觉，我想这是因为当我谈论这个的时候，但是当我在推特上推荐一本书时，人们会说，哦，你就像，泰德，好像我无法成为真正对哲学、神学和文学感到好奇并喜欢这些东西的自己。
And I hope not in an annoying way.
我希望不是以一种令人厌烦的方式。
I just, I went to college, I loved literature, I love reading and talking about things that we love talking about those things.
我只是，我上了大学，我喜欢文学，我喜欢阅读和谈论我们喜欢谈论这些事情的事情。
We do, I mean, it's kind of who we are, it's kind of why we do what we do.
我的意思是，我们就是这样，这就是我们是谁，这就是我们做我们所做的事情的原因。
Right, but I felt like you guys, and again, this is just what we got, we're talking about on this show, you took something about me that I value as a virtue, and you held it up for mockery, and it made me feel like you guys- Are we still having dinner later?
是的，但我和你们的感觉一样，再说一次，这就是我们所得到的，我们在这个节目中谈论的，你们把我视为美德的一些东西拿来嘲笑，这让我感觉像你们——我们稍后还要吃晚饭吗？
Is this you canceling dinner?
这是你取消晚餐吗？
We're gonna talk about this, I'm gonna say how I really feel in general.
我们要讨论这个，我要说一下我的真实感受。
No, but it made me feel like these things that I valued about myself were then suddenly held up from Ocarina, and then when I was myself in the real world, it was self-conscious.
不，但它让我觉得我自己看重的这些东西突然被陶笛挡住了，然后当我在现实世界中做我自己时，它就变得不自在了。
Yeah, people were like, you're just like that and going intellectual guy, because you read books.
是的，人们会说，你就是那样的知识分子，因为你读书。
You like words, you know?
你喜欢文字，你知道吗？
And it is unfair, and I am sorry about that, because that is a mind-fuck what you just described, and I'm like you, I'm the same way.
这是不公平的，我对此感到抱歉，因为你刚才描述的那是他妈的，我和你一样，我也是这样。
I'm like, and Carter's like that too.
我是这样，卡特也是这样。
No, and Carter was legitimately reading, like Teddy Roosevelt biography.
不，卡特正在合法地阅读，比如泰迪·罗斯福的传记。
Yeah, 100%.
是的，100%。
I knew that you guys were like me and were kind of me, but then here's the thing, here's the kicker.
我知道你们和我一样，对我很好，但事情就是这样，问题就在这里。
That's how I felt 18 years ago.
这就是我18年前的感受。
But when I watch it now, it just makes me laugh.
但当我现在看到它时，它只会让我发笑。
It's funny.
很有趣。
No, that's the thing.
不，就是这样。
It's funny.
很有趣。
And it's not as annoying as I remember it being, it's charming, it's like, here's the thing, Ted is a dad before he's a dad.
这不像我记忆中那么烦人，它很迷人，就像，事情是这样的，特德在成为父亲之前就已经是父亲了。
That's a huge part of his pre-dad.
这是他的前父亲的一个重要部分。
He's pre-datic.
他是预科生。
It's, and I love that we leaned into that.
是的，我喜欢我们倾向于这一点。
I don't even know if we knew at first we're doing that.
我什至不知道我们一开始是否知道我们正在这样做。
I think we sort of evolved that.
我认为我们已经进化了这一点。
Like that's a way that Ted is funny.
这就是特德有趣的地方。
He wants to make dad jokes.
他想让爸爸笑话。
He wants to give recommendations.
他想提出建议。
He wants to like solve problems, pros and cons lists.
他喜欢解决问题，列出优点和缺点。
And it's kind of what's great about Ted because when Ted has to be the champion of an episode, his championness comes from that intellect and that philosophical curiosity and all of those great things.
这就是泰德的伟大之处，因为当泰德必须成为一集的冠军时，他的冠军来自于他的智慧和哲学好奇心以及所有这些伟大的事情。
And then when we need him to be the buffooned in a joke, or because he's sort of doing something silly, we would use the sort of shadow side of that and sort of douche him out along those lines a little bit to make that the joke.
然后，当我们需要他成为一个笑话中的小丑，或者因为他做了一些愚蠢的事情时，我们会利用其中的阴暗面，并按照这些方式对他进行一点冲洗，使之成为笑话。
And sort of it's weak to weak that would change.
从某种程度来说，这种情况会发生变化。
It's sort of unfair because the superpower became the sort of flaw that it's a superpower again the next week.
这有点不公平，因为超级大国变成了下周再次成为超级大国的缺陷。
Well, it's the same thing you guys did.
嗯，你们也干过同样的事。
My gripe about drum roll please in the episode following is like in one episode, he's lionized for being the romantic hero.
我对接下来的一集中的鼓声的抱怨就像在一集中一样，他因成为浪漫英雄而受到崇拜。
And the next one, he's completely made fun of for it, for his romanticism.
而下一个，他完全因为他的浪漫主义而被嘲笑。
So cheesy and insufferable, which in a way that was so over the top, and those are tough to latch back to back.
如此俗气和令人难以忍受，在某种程度上太过分了，而且这些很难背靠背地锁住。
It's like, ooh boy, that is a whiplash inducing term.
就像，哦天哪，这是一个引起鞭打的术语。
That's what it felt like being inside it.
这就是身处其中的感觉。
I was like, what is, I called a special meeting with you in Carter to discuss it.
我当时想，什么是，我在卡特与你召开了一次特别会议来讨论这个问题。
Yeah, and it's true, you have to hit the right tone, you have to think long term, you have to think about how people are gonna binge the show.
是的，这是真的，你必须用正确的语气，你必须考虑长远，你必须考虑人们将如何狂欢这个节目。
And it's a hard balance to strike, it really is.
确实，这是一个很难达到的平衡。
But I do find when I watch it now, I'm mostly like, this is harmless fun.
但我确实发现，当我现在看它时，我最喜欢的是，这是无害的乐趣。
Yes.
是的。
And the only thing though that I felt was like, I worry, it's like, there's an anti-intellectual strain of American comedy.
但我唯一感觉到的是，我担心，美国喜剧中有一种反智的倾向。
Oh yes.
哦是的。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, it really is like a kind of, you know, the college boy is not well regarded in the annals of American comedy.
就像，这真的就像一种，你知道，大学男孩在美国喜剧史上并没有得到很好的评价。
And, you know, I did go to college and I do love books and anyone who follows me, you know, what I make and write and gravitate to, like, it's stuff that I just, I find really fascinating, but I also long for depth.
而且，你知道，我确实上过大学，我确实喜欢书籍，所有关注我的人，你知道，我创作、写作和着迷的东西，就像，我发现这些东西真的很迷人，但我也渴望深度。
And so I was trying in my own life to value this stuff and hold it up and then I would go into work and I felt like it was, you know, you know what I mean?
所以我在自己的生活中尝试珍视这些东西并坚持下去，然后我就会投入工作，我觉得，你知道，你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我愿意。
I mean, it's such an interesting like, it's interesting to hear that all these years later and how you felt then and how you look at it now.
我的意思是，这是一个非常有趣的事情，这么多年后听到你当时的感受以及现在的看法很有趣。
It's such a unique circumstance to play this character for nine years.
在这样一个特殊的环境下扮演这个角色长达九年之久。
And like, what other format makes a character have to do as many different things where one week he is the romantic lead and the next week he's like the silly buffoon because of the same character traits.
就像，还有什么其他格式可以让一个角色必须做很多不同的事情，一周他是浪漫的主角，下周他就像一个愚蠢的小丑，因为相同的角色特征。
I know and I have great sympathy for, I have great sympathy for where you guys were in terms of needing to vary things up, needing to change the levels and turn the knobs of all these characters week to week.
我知道，我非常同情，我非常同情你们需要改变事情，需要改变水平并每周转动所有这些角色的旋钮。
I mean, you guys were doing an enormous amount and brilliantly, Siegel and I used to talk about, because we wrote our own things and we said, could we write how I made it?
我的意思是，西格尔和我曾经谈论过，你们做了很多而且非常出色的事情，因为我们写了自己的东西，我们说，我们可以写一下我是如何制作它的吗？
Mother and both of us agreed, we could not.
母亲和我们都同意，但我们不能。
We didn't have the brains for it, the different kind of brain.
我们没有这样的大脑，不同类型的大脑。
Well, we were figuring it out.
好吧，我们正在解决这个问题。
That moment you just talked about it in season one, we were figuring out, but it can't he can't be a different character the next Monday it has to be there has to be some consistency right and I think you that's something you only figure out by doing it and by figuring it out week to week I guess them I guess I felt in season one his most pronounced trait was this kind of like impetuous romanticism yes but as the show went on this intellectual snobbery started to develop right and I think I felt because I did crossword puzzles and was bringing and David Foster Wallace books to read in between takes.
那一刻你刚刚在第一季中谈到了这一点，我们正在弄清楚，但他不能在下周一成为一个不同的角色，它必须有一定的一致性，对吧，我想你只有通过这样做，每周都弄清楚，我想他们我想我在第一季中感觉到他最明显的特征是这种浮躁的浪漫主义，是的，但随着节目的进行，这种知识势利开始发展，我想我觉得是因为我做了填字游戏，并在拍摄间隙带了大卫·福斯特·华莱士的书来阅读。
I felt that you guys were studying me and making fun of me.
我觉得你们在研究我并取笑我。
We're making fun of ourselves.
我们在取笑自己。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
But it was really, I don't know, I was very thin-skinned about it.
但我真的不知道，我对此的脸皮很薄。
But like I said, I watch it now and I hear Jordana laugh at these things and I think like, oh, this wasn't personal.
但就像我说的，我现在看它，我听到乔丹娜嘲笑这些事情，我想，哦，这不是针对个人的。
I took everything personally back then.
那时我把一切都看成是个人的。
But that's the value of looking back at it now.
但这就是现在回顾它的价值。
That's the value of literally what we're doing this very moment.
这就是我们此时此刻正在做的事情的真正价值。
And you're right, because it's just funny now.
你是对的，因为现在很有趣。
I'm watching the episode with Rebecca.
我正在和丽贝卡一起看这一集。
One of the biggest laughs of the whole episode was when their post-coital and Ted corrects her literally as a figuratively.
整集最大的笑点之一是当他们性交后，泰德纠正了她的字面意思。
Like right after he clearly had great sex, but he still just got to be like, well, let's get this right.
就像在他显然有过很棒的性爱之后，但他仍然必须说，好吧，让我们把这件事做好。
With the heavy breathing still in, yeah.
粗重的呼吸声还在，是的。
It's just very funny.
这真是太有趣了。
It's like he's a corrector.
就好像他是一个校正者。
He has, he wants, he likes to be precise.
他有，他想要，他喜欢精确。
He's an architect.
他是一名建筑师。
He likes every detail to be in its place.
他喜欢每个细节都各就其位。
You have to be pretty specific as an architect.
作为一名建筑师，你必须非常具体。
I don't know why when I watch it now.
现在看的时候也不知道为什么。
I just find it pretty charming.
我只是觉得它很迷人。
and actually like harmless.
实际上喜欢无害。
It's great.
这很棒。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It's just, do we all have, you can like, I used to take every, it's the same, every little thing.
只是，我们都有吗，你可以喜欢，我曾经拿过每一件，都是一样的，每一件小事。
I didn't watch the show for so many years before this podcast, because I was afraid I would overanalyze it and be like, that joke could have been better.
在这个播客之前我已经很多年没有看这个节目了，因为我担心我会过度分析它并且觉得，那个笑话本来可以更好。
The internet is right when they say this thing sucked.
当他们说这件事很糟糕时，互联网是正确的。
I remember somebody hated this one or whatever it is.
我记得有人讨厌这个或其他什么。
And then, you know, you just watch it and you experience it.
然后，你知道，你只需观看它并体验它。
And you are a different person watching it right now than you were making it then.
现在观看它的你与当时制作它的你是一个不同的人。
And it's a great feeling.
这是一种很棒的感觉。
I'm loving rewatching it because of that.
因此我很喜欢重看它。
It's kind of the whole, you know, it is like the whole point of what we're doing.
这是整体，你知道，这就像我们正在做的事情的全部意义。
Like we're watching, we're revisiting a classic that we had a hand in bringing to life and we're changed and it has changed in a weird way.
就像我们正在观看的那样，我们正在重温一部我们亲手赋予生命的经典，我们改变了，它以一种奇怪的方式改变了。
It has changed and we're different people.
它已经改变了，我们是不同的人。
And I really, now I can see that Ted was a wannabe dad and he was like, he has all of those traits.
我真的，现在我可以看到特德是一个想成为父亲的人，他就像，他拥有所有这些特征。
It's actually quite well mapped out that he needs, he belongs, he should be those two kids dad.
事实上，他需要、他属于、他应该是那两个孩子的爸爸。
He should, they're on the couch listening to his wisdom.
他应该这样做，他们正在沙发上听他的智慧。
This is what he wanted.
这就是他想要的。
He wanted to be able to impart his wisdom to some people.
他希望能够将他的智慧传授给一些人。
He started doing it to his contemporary age trends in their late twenties.
他在二十多岁的时候就开始针对当代的流行趋势采取这种做法。
And sometimes he'd be like, shut the fuck up, dad.
有时他会说，他妈的闭嘴，爸爸。
You're not really a dad.
你并不是一个真正的父亲。
And sometimes they had to be, but that was his deeper one.
有时他们必须如此，但那是他更深层次的。
But he also went from, he goes from Robin and Barney rolling their eyes at him to his kids rolling their eyes at him.
但他也从罗宾和巴尼对他翻白眼到他的孩子们对他翻白眼。
No, which is by the way, the circle of life.
不，顺便说一句，这是生命的循环。
That's what that's my kids do, that's me all the time.
这就是我的孩子们所做的事情，这就是我一直以来所做的。
Yeah.
是的。
So what were the other, so lilies, where did lilies?
那么其他是什么，百合花，百合花在哪里？
Martial songs, lilies, loud chewing.
武歌，百合，大声咀嚼。
I feel like that might have been somebody in the writer's room being like, I don't even know, and this isn't me trying to forget who not wanting to say the name, but I feel like it's some, or maybe it was some other writer's room, because when you sit there eating around each other for 10 years on a TV show, all you do is eat.
我觉得可能是编剧房间里的某个人，我什至不知道，这并不是我试图忘记谁不想说出这个名字，但我觉得是某个作家的房间，或者可能是其他作家的房间，因为当你在电视节目中坐在一起吃饭十年时，你所做的就是吃。
You're just sitting there eating, and I feel like there were just stories about how some people just, it's really resonant when one person needs two people can eat the same thing and somehow some different acoustics are happening.
你只是坐在那里吃饭，我觉得有一些故事是关于有些人如何，当一个人需要两个人可以吃同样的东西时，这真的很能引起共鸣，并且不知怎的，一些不同的声学效果正在发生。
I think I might have come from like that because you are basically eating around each other the entire time.
我想我可能就是这样的，因为你们基本上一直在互相吃饭。
It's also a classic kind of like you're around someone so long.
这也是一种经典，就像你和某人在一起这么久一样。
It's like a classic like how would I never notice that?
这就像一个经典，我怎么可能从来没有注意到呢？
It's the frog in the boiling water.
这是温水中的青蛙。
You just don't know and Marshall's the frog.
你只是不知道，马歇尔就是青蛙。
He doesn't know that there's this crazy boiling water.
他不知道还有这么疯狂的沸水。
And but you know what?
但你知道吗？
That made me laugh so fucking hard.
这让我笑得很厉害。
Just because it's so stupid.
只因为它太愚蠢了。
the incredibly boosted.
令人难以置信的提升。
I remember doing the sound mix of that episode and being like louder, louder and the sound mix people don't like doing wrong sounding sound effects.
我记得做了那一集的混音，声音越来越大，混音的人不喜欢做错误的声音效果。
You have to like really coax them out to the edge.
你必须真正把他们哄到极限。
And like, I just want you to know, whatever you think is loud enough, it's gonna be 40% louder than that.
就像，我只是想让你知道，无论你认为足够响亮，它都会比那个响亮 40%。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
You have to really like inch them up to the cliff.
你必须真的喜欢把他们推到悬崖上。
Well, to sell those jokes, I mean, again, it's the kind of thing of like, how will people describe this chewing go?
好吧，为了兜售这些笑话，我的意思是，人们会如何描述这种咀嚼果？
you know, like how many different ways and Stephen Lloyd wrote some great that is very like you get Stephen Lloyd that prompt and he will just fucking run with it.
你知道，就像有多少种不同的方式，斯蒂芬·劳埃德写了一些伟大的作品，就像你得到斯蒂芬·劳埃德的提示，他就会他妈的跟着它跑。
And I was like, where did you was it?
我当时想，你在哪里？
Where did you buy that cereal?
你那麦片哪里买的？
Like, was it a home depot or something?
比如，它是一个家得仓库还是什么？
And then all the thing of like a pair of cufflinks being sucked up into a vacuum, like there were those beaut poetic turns of phrase.
然后所有的事情就像一对袖扣被吸进真空，就像那些美丽的诗意的短语一样。
What was the dinosaur role?
恐龙的角色是什么？
Wasn't there a T-rex one?
不是有一只霸王龙吗？
Yeah, yeah, it was like you like he sounded like Jurassic Park or whatever.
是的，是的，就像你一样，他听起来就像侏罗纪公园之类的。
Like, it was so elegantly written over.
就像，它写得如此优雅。
I'm butchering them all, but that was very Stephen Lloyd wheelhouse.
我正在屠杀他们所有人，但这正是斯蒂芬·劳埃德的风格。
I also loved Hannegan's face of like nothing's, we're just, nothing's the problem.
我也喜欢汉尼根的表情，就像什么都没有一样，我们只是，没有什么问题。
Like we're all just eating, like her obliviousness too.
就像我们都只是在吃东西一样，就像她的健忘一样。
And Marshall walking down, also oblivious and happy.
马歇尔走下来，同样健忘而快乐。
There's a shot of the three of you walking down the street and Ted is like, what the fuck is she doing with her mouth?
有一张你们三个人走在街上的镜头，泰德心想，她到底在用嘴做什么？
And Marshall's like, boop, boop, boop, that is so stupid.
马歇尔就像是，噗，噗，噗，这太愚蠢了。
You know, it's so funny is, I mean, Seagull, anytime Seagull had to sing, I think those were all Jason Seagull originals, right?
你知道，这很有趣的是，我的意思是，海鸥，每当海鸥必须唱歌时，我认为这些都是杰森海鸥的原创，对吧？
Did you guys?
你们有吗？
We would just give him words and he would just do it.
我们只要给他一句话，他就会去做。
And he just, Jason Seagull is somebody who he understands the mission.
Jason Seagull 是一个懂得使命的人。
He's just that guy, like, I got it.
他就是那个人，我明白了。
And I think he came up with all the like melodies of all of that stuff.
我认为他想出了所有这些东西的相似旋律。
But also something that is always going to be in my head is and a roll of courses, the roll of courses.
但我脑子里一直萦绕着的一件事就是一卷课程，一卷课程。
Roll of course, yes, the road kind of.
当然是滚动，是的，道路之类的。
So Lillie, I mean, Robins was literally figuratively, right?
所以莉莉，我的意思是，罗宾斯实际上是象征性的，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
And Barney's was, he had like five of them.
巴尼的也是，他有大约五个。
Yeah, but he had a bunch that were just his traits.
是的，但他有很多正是他的特质。
But his traits, but he just like owned them as like, he was the least hurt.
但他的特质，却是他喜欢拥有的，他是受伤害最少的。
He didn't even know what people were talking about.
他甚至不知道人们在谈论什么。
Like, what do you mean?
比如，你什么意思？
I'm just awesome.
我真是太棒了。
Yeah, he's no zero self-awareness and that fits.
是的，他的自我意识不是零，这很合适。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was, yeah, and yeah, Robins was the overuse of literally, I guess, and basically that was her main, was there another one for Robin that came out, or was that it?
那是，是的，是的，罗宾斯是字面意义上的过度使用，我猜，基本上这是她的主要内容，是否有另一个罗宾出现了，或者就是这样？
That might have been the only one.
这可能是唯一的一个。
I mean, Ted could have maybe talked about her love of gun culture.
我的意思是，泰德也许可以谈论她对枪支文化的热爱。
That could have been the thing.
可能就是这样。
Or her intimacy avoidance.
或者她回避亲密关系。
I mean, there were many things that could have, but these were, I think that, I think the point of this is these are innocuous on some level.
我的意思是，有很多事情可以做，但我认为这些是，我认为重点是这些在某种程度上是无害的。
These are completely innocuous.
这些是完全无害的。
These are not character-assassinating things.
这些不是暗杀品格的事情。
They're not like you're actually cruel to people or you have a criminal, you know, sociopathic.
他们并不像你实际上对人很残忍，或者你有一个罪犯，你知道，反社会。
It's just who they are.
他们就是这样的人。
And so it begins, that's why it's a deeper debate.
事情就这样开始了，这就是为什么这是一场更深入的辩论。
It's like, well, you have to love this about me.
就像，好吧，你必须喜欢我的这一点。
If you're going to love me romantically or as a friend, you're probably just going to have to like that I make up these songs.
如果你想浪漫地爱我或者像朋友一样爱我，你可能就必须喜欢我创作的这些歌曲。
Like, I should be with the person who likes my little songs.
就像，我应该和喜欢我的小歌的人在一起。
But isn't it funny, like with a dear friend or a spouse, like one day a thing can be completely charming and delightful.
但这不是很有趣吗，就像和一位亲爱的朋友或配偶在一起一样，有一天一件事可以变得完全迷人和令人愉快。
And if you're just a little like woke up on the wrong side of the bed, it's just like, it's unbearable.
如果你只是在床的错误一侧醒来，那就有点难以忍受。
And it's you know that it's you.
你知道那就是你。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm very relieved that Jordana is out on a walk right now, by the way.
顺便说一句，乔丹娜现在出去散步，我感到非常欣慰。
She just left.
她刚刚离开。
That's why we can talk about this stuff.
这就是为什么我们可以谈论这个东西。
Okay, good.
好的，很好。
Thank God.
感谢上帝。
Okay, let it rip.
好吧，就让它撕裂吧。
Just let it rip.
就让它撕裂吧。
This is the same space.
这是同一个空间。
So there's this article that in 2016, I think, in the New York Times, it was the number one most read and emailed article in the whole paper for the whole year.
我认为 2016 年《纽约时报》上有一篇文章，它是全年全报阅读量和电子邮件发送次数最多的文章。
And it's by this Swiss philosopher named Alain de Bataan, who's really interesting and worth checking out.
这是一位名叫阿兰·德·巴丹（Alain de Bataan）的瑞士哲学家写的，他真的很有趣，值得一看。
He has TED talks.
他有 TED 演讲。
He's a really fascinating guy.
他是一个非常迷人的人。
But the article, the headline is, why you will marry the wrong person.
但这篇文章的标题是，为什么你会嫁错人。
And Alec will put this in the show notes, yeah?
亚历克会把这个写在演出笔记里，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's called why you will marry the wrong person.
这就是为什么你会嫁错人。
Wait, Craig, just read the first...
等等，克雷格，读第一本……
A couple paragraphs a year ago.
一年前的几段话。
Yeah, I just opened it up.
是的，我刚刚打开它。
Okay, I'm gonna read the opening.
好吧，我要读一下开头。
It's great.
这很棒。
This is a fascinating, yeah.
这是一个令人着迷的事情，是的。
Sorry, I had to write why you will marry the wrong person.
抱歉，我必须写为什么你会嫁给错误的人。
It's one of the things we are most afraid might happen to us.
这是我们最害怕发生在我们身上的事情之一。
We go to great lengths to avoid it, and yet we do it all the same.
我们竭尽全力避免它，但我们还是这么做了。
We marry the wrong person.
我们嫁给了错误的人。
Partly it's because we have a bewildering array of problems that emerge when we try to get close to others.
部分原因是当我们试图与他人亲近时，会出现一系列令人眼花缭乱的问题。
We seem normal only to those who don't know us very well.
只有对于那些不太了解我们的人来说，我们才显得正常。
You know, why is there more self-war society than our own?
你知道吗，为什么自战社会比我们社会还多？
A standard question on any early dinner date would be, and how are you crazy?
任何早晚餐约会的标准问题都是，你怎么疯了？
Perhaps we have a latent tendency to get furious when someone disagrees with us, or can relax only when we're working.
也许我们有一种潜在的倾向，当有人不同意我们的观点时我们会变得愤怒，或者只有当我们工作时才能放松。
Perhaps we're tricky about intimacy after sex, or clam up in response to humiliation.
也许我们对性行为后的亲密关系感到棘手，或者对羞辱保持沉默。
Nobody's perfect.
没有人是完美的。
The problem is that before marriage, we rarely delve into our complexities.
问题是，在结婚之前，我们很少深入研究自己的复杂性。
It goes on from there, which is great.
它从那里继续，这很棒。
Yeah, really worth reading.
是的，确实值得一读。
But I thought...
但我想...
It's brilliant.
太棒了。
Really, it really hits on something in this episode.
真的，这一集中确实击中了一些东西。
I mean, this is a good story.
我的意思是，这是一个好故事。
One of the privileges of being on our own is therefore the sincere impression that we are really quite easy to live with.
因此，独自生活的好处之一就是给人一种真诚的印象：我们真的很容易相处。
It's exactly, I mean, it's really on topic of this episode.
我的意思是，这正是本集的主题。
So I think that I wanted to talk about this because there is a thing where dating, like the difference between dating and marriage is almost hilarious.
所以我想我想谈论这个是因为约会有一件事，就像约会和婚姻之间的区别几乎是搞笑的。
Like how we were dating to figure out if we wanna marry someone, these are not, these are in different universes, you know?
就像我们如何约会以确定我们是否想与某人结婚一样，这些不是，它们位于不同的宇宙中，你知道吗？
I think there's a great Chris Rockline about how like, you're not actually dating someone, the person you're dating their representative or ambassador, like they send out an ambassador on behalf of themselves to like make it all look kind of good.
我认为克里斯·洛克莱恩（Chris Rockline）有一个很棒的说法，你实际上并不是在和某个人约会，你正在和他们的代表或大使约会的人，就像他们代表自己派出一位大使一样，让一切看起来都很好。
That's brilliant.
太棒了。
And there's something like, I don't know, there's something, I think this is both a pro and a con about marriage and it's the same thing, which is that you will see a lot of yourself.
有一些东西，我不知道，有一些东西，我认为这对于婚姻来说既有利又不利，而且是同一件事，那就是你会看到很多自己。
you will see a lot of yourself from, you know, like if you're living alone and you're lying on the couch and scrolling on the phone for four hours, no one's there to look at you and be like, you've been on the couch a long time scrolling on your phone, you know, either just the look, or just their presence makes you realize that you're doing it.
你会看到很多自己，你知道，就像你一个人住，躺在沙发上玩手机四个小时，没有人看着你，就像你已经在沙发上玩手机很长时间了，你知道，要么只是外表，要么只是他们的存在让你意识到你正在这样做。
You can, there's so much delusion that's available to you if you're not living with someone, whether it's roommates or a spouse, you know.
你可以，如果你不和某人住在一起，无论是室友还是配偶，你知道，你就会产生很多错觉。
And I just think it's such a funny thing to encounter your own insanity, vis-a-vis another person.
我只是觉得在另一个人面前遭遇自己的疯狂是一件很有趣的事情。
And it feels like even the happiest marriages contain this level of like, one, it's like, you see things about the other person, but also like, you know that they're seeing things about you, that you have deluded yourself into thinking are not that big a deal, but then you're like, yeah, this is actually pretty annoying, this thing I do.
感觉即使是最幸福的婚姻也包含这样的程度，一，就像，你看到了对方的事情，但也就像，你知道他们正在看到你的事情，你欺骗自己认为这没什么大不了的，但后来你会想，是的，这实际上很烦人，我做的这件事。
Accepting that you're also annoying and that however annoying you are, they're also going to be annoyed by you.
接受你也很烦人的事实，无论你有多烦人，他们也会被你惹恼。
And I liked in this article, it was pro-pessimism, this article, in a weird way to do.
我喜欢这篇文章，它是支持悲观主义的，这篇文章以一种奇怪的方式去做。
That was such a surprising choice.
这实在是一个令人惊讶的选择。
I'm trying to find that part, he says, the philosophy of pessimism offers a solution to a lot of distress and agitation around marriage.
他说，我正在努力找到那部分，悲观主义哲学为婚姻中的许多痛苦和不安提供了解决方案。
It might sound odd, but pessimism relieves the excessive imaginative pressure that our romantic culture places upon marriage, The failure of one particular partner to save us from our grief and melancholy is not an argument against that person and no sign that a union deserves to fail or be upgraded.
这可能听起来很奇怪，但悲观主义缓解了我们的浪漫文化对婚姻施加的过度想象压力。某个特定伴侣未能将我们从悲伤和忧郁中拯救出来，这并不是反对那个人的论点，也没有迹象表明婚姻应该失败或升级。
It's such an interesting idea of like, just, whoever you wind up with will be flawed and so are you and so don't panic if you realize that.
这是一个非常有趣的想法，就像，无论你最终和谁在一起都会有缺陷，你也是，所以如果你意识到这一点，不要惊慌。
So that's interesting why this episode, maybe Ted should have stuck it out a little longer.
所以这很有趣，为什么这一集，也许泰德应该再坚持一会儿。
He also said something interesting that I don't know if it was in this episode or another episode.
他还说了一些有趣的话，我不知道是在这一集还是另一集中。
I mean, in this thing or in one of his talks, But he said there's a benefit to getting married later.
我的意思是，在这件事或他的一次谈话中，但他说晚点结婚有好处。
Does he say this in there?
他在里面说这个吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Well, his point is, by the time you get to be older, you know, say, for instance, you get gloomy on Sunday nights.
嗯，他的观点是，当你长大后，你知道，比如说，你会在周日晚上变得阴郁。
You get weird on Sundays.
周日你会变得很奇怪。
If you get married too young and you don't know that about yourself, you might blame your partner for that.
如果你结婚太早，而你又不了解自己，你可能会因此责怪你的伴侣。
But if you get married a little bit older, you can go, hey, just the heads up, I get weird on Sundays.
但如果你结婚的年龄大一点，你可以说，嘿，请注意，我周日会变得很奇怪。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, Sunday nights will be.
你知道，周日晚上会。
Yeah, here's the user manual.
是的，这是用户手册。
Yes, yes, you know your own kind of user manual and you're less apt to blame the other person and it's funny because Except for Marshall and Lily.
是的，是的，你知道你自己的用户手册，你不太容易责怪别人，这很有趣，因为除了马歇尔和莉莉。
No one is romantically involved with the other person and anyone else, you know Robin and Ted aren't together Barney and Robin aren't yet together.
没有人与另一个人和其他任何人有浪漫关系，你知道罗宾和泰德没有在一起，巴尼和罗宾还没有在一起。
Yeah, this is really Um, I mean there's two levels.
是的，这确实是，嗯，我的意思是有两个层次。
There's you know them trying to warn Ted off this woman, but there's also this this Spider-Man finger pointing meme, where everyone is kind of pointing out the thing about each other.
你知道他们试图警告特德远离这个女人，但也有这个蜘蛛侠指责模因，每个人都在互相指出对方的事情。
But also that level of insight into another person, what is kind of annoying, and the courage to be able to tell it is a sign of intimacy.
而且对另一个人的洞察力，什么是令人讨厌的，以及能够说出它的勇气是亲密的标志。
Right, and I think that's talked about in that article too, it's like that actually is intimacy.
是的，我想那篇文章也谈到了这一点，这实际上就是亲密关系。
It's having the courage and the guts to risk that with somebody and to do.
就是有勇气和胆量与某人一起冒险并去做。
Well, he says the day your marriage begins the day you wake up and say, what have I done?
好吧，他说，从你的婚姻开始的那一天起，你醒来问，我做了什么？
What have I done?
我做了什么？
Yeah.
是的。
That's when the hard work of marriage kind of kicks in, right?
这就是婚姻的辛苦工作开始发挥作用的时候，对吗？
Because you're just having to, I think it's less, honestly, about a confrontation with the other and more about confrontation with self.
因为你只是不得不这样做，老实说，我认为这不是与他人的对抗，而是与自我的对抗。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这个老人，他必须让我爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
One thing I like bringing it back to the sort of the surprise plot twist in this episode, that marshals, the fact that marshals annoying song trade is the thing that solves the other big mystery in this episode, the other big, the actual stakes of this episode, besides, is dad gonna break up with this woman that we just met.
我喜欢把它带回到这一集中那种令人惊讶的情节转折，即元帅，事实上，元帅恼人的歌曲交易解决了这一集的另一个大谜团，这一集的另一个大的、实际的利害关系，除此之外，爸爸要和我们刚刚认识的这个女人分手。
The realer stakes in some ways is, is Marshall gonna become a lawyer today?
在某些方面，真正的赌注是，马歇尔今天会成为一名律师吗？
So you'll find out he passed the bar and his life isn't forever changed by that one piece of information.
所以你会发现他通过了律师资格认证，而且他的生活并没有因为这条信息而永远改变。
He's lost the password to log in and find the bar results that just went live.
他丢失了登录密码并查找刚刚上线的酒吧结果。
And he's getting all these calls from all his friends.
他接到了所有朋友打来的电话。
I'm a lawyer.
我是一名律师。
And it's been driving him fucking crazy.
这让他快要发疯了。
And he can't find it.
而他找不到它。
And then the fact that his flaw is also the key that solves the puzzle box of this episode.
事实上，他的缺陷也是解决这一集谜题的关键。
I think it's a beautiful idea.
我认为这是一个美好的主意。
It's very deep, it's very, yes, in quotes.
它非常深，非常，是的，用引号引起来。
It's also just like a very satisfying, it's so funny, there's two mysteries running, like what is Marshall's password and what's wrong with Ted's new girlfriend?
这也就像一个非常令人满意、非常有趣的故事，有两个谜团在运行，比如马歇尔的密码是什么以及泰德的新女友出了什么问题？
Yes.
是的。
But there's something just satisfying almost in an Agatha Christie type way.
但有一些东西几乎以阿加莎克里斯蒂式的方式令人满意。
It's a mystery.
这是一个谜。
It's totally a mystery, yes.
是的，这完全是一个谜。
Oh my God, that's the thing.
天啊，原来是这样啊。
and that the song unlocks the password and then they all gather round and then just get to celebrate.
这首歌解锁了密码，然后他们都聚集在一起庆祝。
Oh, it's so sweet.
哦，太甜了。
I really loved that.
我真的很喜欢那个。
I loved Apple orchard Banana Cat Dance 8, 6, 6, 3, Rachel Ziegler, you know that act the actress Rachel Ziegler, she's a white side story, huge hymium fan, and she once sent me on like Twitter or something, a video of her singing that song.
我喜欢《苹果园香蕉猫之舞 8, 6, 6, 3》，Rachel Ziegler，你知道那个演员 Rachel Ziegler，她是一个白人旁白，是 hymium 的超级粉丝，她曾经在 Twitter 上给我发了一段她唱那首歌的视频。
And when I got the video, I went, I forget what episode that was completely forgot.
当我拿到视频时，我就去了，我忘记了完全忘记了哪一集。
What if that was her audition for Steven Spielberg for West Side Story?
如果那是她为史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格主演的《西区故事》试镜怎么办？
That was her audition for West Side Story.
那是她参加《西区故事》的试镜。
And that's how she got the role.
这就是她得到这个角色的方式。
But she was, I love that she's such a big fan.
但她是，我喜欢她这么大的粉丝。
She also has a video for singing other hymium songs.
她还有一个演唱其他 hymium 歌曲的视频。
It's like very cool that she, but I love that she's not the only fan that loves that one little bit.
她很酷，但我喜欢她不是唯一喜欢这一点的粉丝。
That one little thing.
那一件小事。
And I think it's because it's so satisfying in this episode.
我认为这是因为这一集非常令人满意。
genuinely the solution to the miss.
真正解决了错过的问题。
It really does feel like the Sherlock Holmes has solved the case.
确实感觉福尔摩斯已经破案了。
The fact that that is the code, the A, B, O, blah, blah, blah, number number, and that is how we get to it.
事实上，这就是代码，A、B、O、等等、等等、数字，这就是我们得到它的方式。
It's such a great, they're fighting and they're fighting and they're fighting and then they're like completely jubilant one second later.
这太棒了，他们在战斗，他们在战斗，他们在战斗，然后下一秒他们就完全欢呼起来。
And I think that by accepting that flaw and seeing now his flaw has saved the day, I think it's actually making kind of a nice statement that.
我认为，通过接受这个缺陷并现在看到他的缺陷挽救了这一天，我认为这实际上是一个很好的声明。
And again, I think that there's something, your ability and your willingness to write flawed characters who know their flawed, who love, you know, I love that quote, we don't love because of, we love in spite of.
再说一次，我认为有一些东西，你的能力和愿意写出有缺陷的角色，他们知道自己的缺陷，他们爱，你知道，我喜欢那句话，我们不爱是因为，我们爱尽管。
Yes.
是的。
You know, this is really an example of that.
你知道，这确实是一个例子。
But I think it's kind of, like when we lead with vulnerability, when we lead with our flaws, it does elicit a certain amount of trust.
但我认为这有点像当我们以脆弱性来领导时，当我们以我们的缺陷来领导时，它确实会引起一定程度的信任。
You know, if someone walks in and they're like, you know, like Alec Baldwin and Glenn Gary Gillan Ross, you're just like, kind of, I gotta get away from this guy.
你知道，如果有人走进来，他们会说，你知道，就像亚历克·鲍德温和格伦·加里·吉兰·罗斯，你就会说，我得离开这个家伙。
Like, I don't care about his watch.
就像，我不在乎他的手表。
Like he's really, this is not gonna be a good friend of mine.
就像他真的一样，这不会成为我的好朋友。
You know?
你知道？
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
But if someone comes in not in a totally self-disrespecting way, but I always trust people who are alert to their own flaws, it tells me they have, you know, the ability to self-critique their onto themselves there.
但如果有人不是以一种完全不自尊的方式出现，但我总是相信那些对自己的缺点保持警惕的人，这告诉我他们有，你知道的，有能力自我批评自己。
You know, it's, it's, you know.
你知道，它是，它是，你知道。
I always never shied away from your own flaws, Craig.
我总是从不回避你自己的缺点，克雷格。
You're pretty up front about them.
你对他们很坦率。
I think that's how you connect to people, right?
我想这就是你与人交往的方式，对吧？
It's that is how you connect.
这就是你的联系方式。
You're like, this is what's stupid about me.
你说，这就是我的愚蠢之处。
I, therefore, I will accept that about you too.
因此，我也会接受你的这一点。
And in the end of this episode, I find it very sweet that all of their flaws are coming out or as they're celebrating Marshall and no one's noticing, because they're just having this great, they realize a landmark moment has happened in Marshall's life.
在这一集的结尾，我发现很甜蜜的是，他们所有的缺点都出来了，或者当他们庆祝马歇尔时，没有人注意到，因为他们只是享受这伟大的时刻，他们意识到马歇尔生命中发生了一个里程碑式的时刻。
They've all shared it because they love each other.
他们都分享了它，因为他们彼此相爱。
Right, and again, when you're in love, when you're in your heart, those things don't- You don't notice them anymore.
是的，再说一遍，当你恋爱时，当你在心里时，那些东西就不会——你不再注意到它们了。
At the end of the episode, they go back to not noticing them because something amazing has happened for their friend whom they love.
在这一集的结尾，他们又不再注意到他们，因为他们所爱的朋友发生了一些令人惊奇的事情。
You know, a friend of mine who's older, but him and his wife would teach relationship classes and stuff, and they're very brilliant people, but I asked him, this is years ago, and I said, what's the problem, like what's the central problem with most relationships?
你知道，我的一个朋友年纪大了，但他和他的妻子会教授人际关系课程之类的东西，他们都是非常聪明的人，但我问他，这是几年前的事了，我说，问题是什么，就像大多数关系的核心问题是什么？
And he said, the very thing that draws you to someone, curdles and kind of becomes toxic.
他说，那些吸引你的东西，会凝固，甚至变得有毒。
So if you, when you're falling in love, it's, oh my God, he's so responsible with money.
所以，如果你，当你坠入爱河时，天哪，他对金钱是如此负责任。
And then three years later, he's so cheap, you know?
三年后，他变得如此廉价，你知道吗？
Like, oh, he's so, like he really values home time.
就像，哦，他真的很珍惜在家的时间。
He's such a good, like homebody.
他真是个好人，像个居家男人。
He won't go to a party to save his life.
他不会为了救自己的命而去参加聚会。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
These things just become the very thing that drew you becomes a liability, and you just kind of navigate that stuff.
这些东西变成了吸引你的东西，变成了一种负担，而你只是在处理这些东西。
But I think the more alert we are to our own nonsense and our own flaws, the more forgiving we can be of others.
但我认为，我们对自己的胡言乱语和自己的缺点越警惕，我们就越能宽容他人。
I mean, in a way, it's what we were talking about about watching the show again 20 years later and the things we were so sensitive about or so alert to, oh my God, there's gonna be this, I'm gonna, someone doesn't like this or someone's making fun of me or this thing.
我的意思是，在某种程度上，这就是我们在谈论 20 年后再次观看这部剧时所谈论的，以及我们对这些事情如此敏感或如此警觉的事情，天哪，将会有这个，我会，有人不喜欢这个，或者有人在取笑我或这件事。
It's really, it really comes out on the fucking wash, right?
真的，真的是洗完澡就出来了，对吧？
It really does over time.
随着时间的推移，确实如此。
And you just throw your arms around that younger version of yourself and you go, I see you buddy, I see you, I love you, you're okay.
然后你就用双臂拥抱年轻的自己，然后你就走了，我看到你了，伙计，我看到你了，我爱你，你没事。
I imagine it's the same like when you're neurotic about parenting and then you're like at their college graduation and you're like, man, we kind of over worried.
我想这就像当你对养育孩子感到神经质时，然后你就像在他们的大学毕业典礼上，你会说，伙计，我们有点过度担心了。
Like they did okay, like everything worked out, like you just gotta, yeah.
就像他们做得很好，就像一切都很顺利，就像你必须，是的。
So just a couple of things that I thought were so funny and clever in this episode, I loved Robin's line.
所以，我认为这一集中有几件事非常有趣和聪明，我喜欢罗宾的台词。
She's a keeper, just keeper somewhere.
她是一个守护者，只是守护在某个地方。
Oh my God, it's, that's such a funny line.
天哪，这真是一句有趣的台词。
That is like a vaudeville joke.
这就像一个杂耍笑话。
Totally, totally vaudeville joke, yeah.
完全，完全是杂耍笑话，是的。
Still good, it is good at those.
还是不错的，它擅长这些。
Who are the guys who puked and ran out screaming?
那些呕吐并尖叫着跑出去的人是谁？
Oh, it's in the bar, the bar exam?
哦，是在酒吧，律师考试？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I was wondering if those actors have that on their reel.
我想知道那些演员的片子上是否有这个。
I know, I'm the guy that ran out screaming.
我知道，我就是那个尖叫着跑出去的人。
Like, that was funny.
就像，那很有趣。
It was a good screaming run out of it.
这是一次很好的尖叫。
It was very loud.
声音很大。
Barney's obsession with showing Marshall the video of a dog, putting that up to him.
巴尼痴迷于向马歇尔展示一只狗的视频，并将其交给他。
And again, he has to be a sociopath.
再说一次，他必须是一个反社会者。
He has to create, he creates a days long back story about, he's gonna, he's got a guy.
他必须创造，他创造了一个长达一天的背景故事，关于，他会，他有一个人。
Yeah.
是的。
The government is involved.
政府参与其中。
He has an aria about the- To get him to watch a video of a dog pooping on a baby.
他有一首咏叹调是关于-让他观看狗在婴儿身上拉屎的视频。
And cock-ass banial.
还有平庸的鸡巴。
And then golden reliever was gonna be next.
然后下一个就是金色中继投手。
Yeah.
是的。
These are all Steven Lloyd 101.
这些都是史蒂文·劳埃德 101。
Steven Lloyd is just a genius.
史蒂文·劳埃德只是一个天才。
I love what you guys found.
我喜欢你们发现的东西。
Like Robyn, when Robyn tells a joke that doesn't work and won't like take the L.
就像 Robyn 一样，当 Robyn 讲了一个不起作用并且不喜欢拿 L 的笑话时。
Yeah.
是的。
is so funny.
太搞笑了。
Ted's imagining of what could be wrong with her is so funny.
特德想象她可能出了什么问题真是太有趣了。
Yes, those were very elaborate.
是的，那些非常复杂。
Those were very dark.
那些非常黑暗。
Those were all steep.
这些都很陡峭。
Any time you see something very elaborate or neatly worded and supremely dark, that is Stephen Lloyd, that's just like put it.
每当你看到一些非常复杂或措辞简洁且极其黑暗的东西时，那就是斯蒂芬·劳埃德，就像说的那样。
It didn't get rewritten at all.
它根本没有被重写。
You'll notice some many seasons later, the murder house was complimented.
你会注意到很多季之后，谋杀屋受到了称赞。
The murder house is a Stephen Lloyd.
凶杀案的凶手是斯蒂芬·劳埃德。
And again, to bring it back to around, I don't want to, I, you have some other tidbits, maybe Josh, but Stephen Lloyd is in the tag and he plays, he plays a deaf character, slightly problematic.
再说一遍，我不想，我，你还有一些其他的花絮，也许是乔什，但斯蒂芬·劳埃德在标签中，他扮演，他扮演一个聋子角色，有点问题。
Alec, I would say, right?
亚历克，我会说，对吧？
We probably should have given that to a deaf actor.
我们或许应该把它交给一位聋哑演员。
But here we are.
但我们到了。
It was, it was a long time ago, we're learning.
是的，那是很久以前的事了，我们正在学习。
But we, you know, it's his Alfred Hitchcock cameo and the piece of work he, he wrote.
但我们，你知道，这是他在阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克 (Alfred Hitchcock) 中客串的作品，也是他写的作品。
So it was, it felt like it was fun to see the writer be in an episode, but also Ted shattering him.
是的，看到编剧出现在剧集中感觉很有趣，但泰德也粉碎了他。
Ted shattering and ruining her for him.
特德为他粉碎并毁掉了她。
And the idea, I had forgotten that we did the very meta weird joke that the shattering glass was in parenthetical as a caption.
这个想法，我忘记了我们做了一个非常奇怪的笑话，破碎的玻璃作为标题放在括号中。
You didn't actually hear the glass that time, it's a very thinkery joke.
那一次你实际上并没有听到玻璃的声音，这是一个非常深思熟虑的笑话。
But he, you see it being destroyed, Stephen Lloyd acted that very well, seeing that moment land on his face, whereas he's just ruined for him now too, for Ted, I don't like Ted really meant to do that.
但是他，你看到它被摧毁了，史蒂芬·劳埃德表现得很好，看到那一刻落在他的脸上，而他现在也毁了他，对特德来说，我不喜欢特德真的想这么做。
I love Barney's story about Lucilla in Rio.
我喜欢巴尼关于里约卢西拉的故事。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah.
是的。
What does this have to do with Kathy?
这和凯西有什么关系？
He's such a sociopath, narcissist.
他是个反社会者，自恋者。
You know what made me laugh that Josh Radner did?
你知道乔什·拉德纳的行为让我发笑吗？
What did Josh Radner do?
乔什·拉德纳做了什么？
When she was telling her stories that would stop going on, and he was just like looking at her like, oh my god, this is great stuff.
当她讲述她的故事时，故事就停止了，他看着她，就像，天哪，这真是太棒了。
Yeah, that was really funny.
是的，那真的很有趣。
Before the illusion was shattered, that he did some very good reacting there, and he's just in.
在幻想破灭之前，他在那里做出了一些非常好的反应，而且他刚刚进入。
Because she's beautiful.
因为她很漂亮。
Yeah, she's fantastic.
是的，她太棒了。
She's cool, and he likes her at that point, and I took note of that.
她很酷，他当时就喜欢她，我注意到了这一点。
That was some good acting.
那是一些很好的表演。
Yeah.
是的。
I didn't want to joke at first who said that oh my god, Robin.
我一开始并不想开玩笑，谁说这句话的，天哪，罗宾。
It was, yeah, it was right.
是的，这是对的。
Yeah, I don't want to joke at first.
是的，一开始我不想开玩笑。
That's another dark Steven.
那是另一个黑暗的史蒂文。
I really liked the anti kind of romantic montage that mirrors the first one where Ted's just walking away and jogging up ahead.
我真的很喜欢那种反浪漫的蒙太奇，它反映了第一个场景，泰德只是走开，慢跑在前面。
Yeah.
是的。
It was really funny.
真的很有趣。
You had some good.
你有一些好的。
This is a good episode.
这是一个很好的插曲。
You were a decent place to say that I met Lindsey.
你是一个不错的地方说我遇见了林赛。
at this episode, and we, this is not, who that friend was talking about, but we went out a couple times and we really were drawn to each other and then we reconnected a couple months after this episode and then we were together for about a year.
在这一集中，我们，这不是那个朋友在谈论的人，但我们出去了几次，我们真的被彼此吸引了，然后我们在这一集后几个月重新联系，然后我们在一起大约一年。
And it was wonderful.
这太棒了。
She's a wonderful, if she, I doubt she's listening, but hello, Lindsay, if you're out there.
她是一个很棒的人，如果她，我怀疑她在听的话，但是你好，林赛，如果你在场的话。
She's very talented and funny.
她很有才华而且很有趣。
She's great.
她很棒。
Very talented, very funny.
非常有才华，非常有趣。
Did you meet her through this episode or did you met her before?
你是通过这一集认识她的还是之前认识她的？
Okay, yeah, yeah.
好吧，是啊，是啊。
She was great.
她很棒。
She was a delight to work with us.
她很高兴与我们一起工作。
Yeah, yeah, I thought she was just a, she was wonderful.
是啊，是啊，我以为她只是一个，她很棒。
And I loved, why do you think I called her Chewbacca?
我爱过，你认为我为什么叫她楚巴卡？
Oh my God, because it's the, she wears lots of shiny belts and I resemble a young Harrison Ford.
天哪，因为它是，她戴着很多闪亮的腰带，而我就像年轻的哈里森·福特。
Yes, which I thought was funny.
是的，我觉得这很有趣。
And now Marshall made a Harrison Ford joke, yet again, how I made your mother a prophecy.
现在马歇尔再次开了哈里森·福特的玩笑，我如何让你的母亲成为预言。
It's serious prophecy.
这是一个严肃的预言。
It's freaky, it's genuinely freaky.
太奇怪了，真的太奇怪了。
There's a bunch of those.
有很多这样的。
Yeah, I loved how loud the cotton candy was that Lily was.
是的，我喜欢莉莉棉花糖的声音。
Oh my God, that specific sound was genius too.
天哪，那个特定的声音也太天才了。
Like I can't even, it was, there's some very good sound work, but I remember having to torture the sound mix people being like, yeah, Barney bringing in the CD software, old tech alert.
就像我什至不能，确实有一些非常好的声音作品，但我记得不得不折磨声音混合，人们就像，是的，巴尼引入了 CD 软件，旧的技术警报。
I like the Patriot Act reference was really funny.
我喜欢《爱国者法案》的参考，这真的很有趣。
Also, Marshall's paying of checks sounded like old spirituals, like old, like he was really diggin' deep.
而且，马歇尔的支票支付听起来就像古老的圣歌，古老，就像他真的在深入挖掘。
Siegel just channeled these things.
西格尔只是传达了这些事情。
Like just he was, he had different genres going on.
就像他一样，他有不同的流派。
He had, yeah, he had all, he covered a lot of musical basses with those songs.
他拥有，是的，他拥有一切，他用这些歌曲覆盖了很多低音。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And the apple orchard one has this, rah, kind of like old, like a little ragtime, a little old Broadway, there's, it's genius.
苹果园里有这个，啊，有点像旧的，像一点拉格泰姆，一点旧的百老汇，有，这是天才。
I know.
我知道。
All right.
好的。
Yeah, I mean, you guys, you guys had a lot of different comedy traditions to plunder from, and when you use them all.
是的，我的意思是，你们有很多不同的喜剧传统可以借鉴，当你们全部使用时。
This was a good one.
这是一件好事。
This is a good Gantt group episode.
这是一个很好的甘特图组剧集。
Everyone's on the same topic.
每个人都在谈论同一个话题。
One big idea, two mysteries that are related.
一个伟大的想法，两个相关的谜团。
And it also deepened the lore, and it also every bit in here, in some ways gave you a different weapon for later, like a different comedic weapon for later.
它也加深了传说，而且它在这里的每一点，在某些方面都为你以后提供了不同的武器，就像以后的不同喜剧武器一样。
You could always go back to one of the spoiler alert things for a very solid laugh.
你总是可以回到剧透警告的事情之一，以获得非常可靠的笑声。
And they all came from character, but in some way, Lilies is just ridiculous, I guess, but like they, yeah, I feel like, I don't know that that one ever returned.
他们都来自性格，但在某种程度上，莉莉丝只是荒谬，我猜，但像他们一样，是的，我觉得，我不知道那个人曾经回来过。
Yeah, I'm not sure we ever brought that one back.
是的，我不确定我们是否把那个带回来了。
That might have been the one up, but all the other ones kind of came from character.
这可能是其中之一，但所有其他的都来自性格。
But I like, yeah, I like this one.
但我喜欢，是的，我喜欢这个。
This is a good, this is a good, the mini mystery and the filling in of the lore.
这是一件好事，这是一件好事，迷你神秘和传说的填充。
These are two, we've discovered and rewatching.
这是我们发现并重新观看的两个。
Those are two real hymium strengths and we had them both.
这是两个真正的 hymium 优势，我们两者都有。
And again, really about, about something, like about something that if you're, if you're living living in a society with friends and trying to have relationships like this is an episode that you will relate to.
再说一次，真的是关于某件事，比如关于某件事，如果你生活在一个与朋友一起的社会中，并试图建立这样的关系，那么你就会有这样的经历。
Yeah.
是的。
And you could argue it either way.
无论哪种方式你都可以争论。
You know, it wasn't right to say it was wrong to say it that Ted Ted spoils it for someone else moving forward.
你知道，说泰德·泰德破坏了其他人前进的说法是错误的，这是不对的。
So the sort of chain of spoiling continues.
因此，这种破坏链仍在继续。
Well, it's so high stakes like it's so high stakes.
好吧，这赌注是如此之高，就像它的赌注如此之高一样。
Every girlfriend Ted has is so high stakes, especially for Marshall and Lilly, because it's the front, it's the front porch, you know, it's the front porch and they don't want to listen to her blabber on forever on the porch when they're 90 when they're in the home together.
泰德的每一个女朋友都面临着很高的风险，尤其是对马歇尔和莉莉来说，因为这是前面，这是前廊，你知道，这是前廊，他们不想在90岁的时候一起在家里听她永远在门廊上胡言乱语。
on together or the way we make them look they're 57 but they look 90 we are up to one of our favorite segments on the show we call it the sea block this is the sea block and we don't know why we do that but we like it so we we like to open the show the voice note from from you guys and we close the show is this NPR what I don't know what it just really call for you know what it is.
一起，或者我们让他们看起来57岁但他们看起来90岁的方式，我们正在节目中我们最喜欢的片段之一，我们称之为“海区”，这就是“海区”，我们不知道为什么要这样做，但我们喜欢它，所以我们想以你们的语音留言来打开节目，我们结束节目是这个NPR，我不知道它真正的名字是什么，你知道它是什么。
This is for our nighttime listeners were down shifting we are bringing it down to the adrenaline of the early sessions and we're bringing we're bringing it down to the sea block and if you would like to send us a voice note or a written note about your love of how I may mother, whatever the show means to you.
这是为了我们的夜间听众，我们正在将其降低到早期会议的肾上腺素水平，我们将其降低到海边，如果您愿意向我们发送语音或书面信息，表达您对我可能如何做母亲的爱，无论节目对您意味着什么。
We love to hear from you.
我们很高兴收到您的来信。
Go to HWMYM, how we made your mother.com.
访问 HWMYM，我们是如何创建您的 mother.com 的。
Go to contact and follow the directions.
前往联系方式并按照说明进行操作。
It's very easy.
这很容易。
And we are going to conclude today's show with a letter from Samir in Brookline, Massachusetts.
我们将以一封来自马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩的萨米尔的信来结束今天的节目。
Conan O'Brien's hometown.
柯南·奥布莱恩的家乡。
Yeah, and I'll just say that as you'll see what this letter is gonna bring up is the fact that a lot of people are just finding this podcast right now, which we love.
是的，我只想说，正如您所看到的，这封信将提出一个事实，即很多人现在才发现这个播客，我们喜欢它。
We love they're finally here in season three.
我们很高兴他们终于在第三季出现了。
Please obviously tell your friends about it.
请务必告诉您的朋友。
We also want to honor the fact that just because you have found us later on, we know you have a lot to say about seasons one and seasons two.
我们还想尊重这样一个事实：仅仅因为您后来找到了我们，我们就知道您对第一季和第二季有很多话要说。
We don't want you to feel like we don't want to hear your ideas from before, from the past.
我们不希望您觉得我们不想听到您以前的想法。
So Sameer is going to do that for us.
所以 Sameer 将为我们做这件事。
He found us recently.
他最近找到了我们。
I'm glad.
我很高兴。
But there's so much to say about all the stuff you missed.
但对于你错过的所有东西，还有很多话要说。
So he's trying to- I hope it's compliments.
所以他正在努力——我希望这是赞美。
So this is from some here in Brooklyn, Massachusetts, greetings.
这是来自马萨诸塞州布鲁克林的一些人的问候。
I love him.
我爱他。
I'm a 54-year-old guy who went to the same high school as Craig.
我今年 54 岁，和克雷格在同一所高中。
What high school is that, Craig?
那是哪所高中，克雷格？
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
But it would be a little bit older than he was a four-year-year, so I wouldn't, I was, my brain is raising Schreiber High School in Port Washington, Long Island, but we would be right.
但这比他四岁的年龄要大一点，所以我不会，我是，我的大脑正在培养长岛华盛顿港的施赖伯高中，但我们是对的。
We would have maybe overlapped by a minute, but very, okay, I would have been just coming in when he's leaving.
我们可能会重叠一分钟，但是非常，好吧，当他离开时我就进来了。
continues.
继续。
I watched the show through its entire initial broadcast when my girlfriend and then wife Julie lived on the Upper West Side and then in Brookline, Massachusetts.
当我的女朋友和当时的妻子朱莉住在上西区，然后住在马萨诸塞州的布鲁克莱恩时，我从头到尾观看了该节目的整个播出。
I watched it again with my kids several years ago and I've seen scattered episodes again when my daughter Ella rewatched it.
几年前我和我的孩子们又看了一遍，当我女儿艾拉重看时，我又看到了零散的剧集。
I was thrilled to hear an ad for William, how we made your mother a couple of weeks ago and then Crestfallen a couple days later.
我很高兴听到威廉的广告，几周前我们如何让你的母亲，几天后我们如何让你垂头丧气。
When I found out I had missed over a season and a half.
当我发现我已经错过了一个半赛季的时候。
I'm catching up.
我正在追赶。
But I'm sad I missed my chances to participate in the discussion so far.
但我很遗憾到目前为止我错过了参与讨论的机会。
It's not too late.
还不算太晚。
Here we are.
我们到了。
We're discussing you right now.
我们现在正在讨论你。
By regret that having missed out is so great that I'm going to risk alienating myself and getting all subsequent emails trashed, unopened by using this first one to make a comment on your first few episodes through the Blue French Horn nay pilot episode.
遗憾的是，错过的机会是如此之大，以至于我将冒着疏远自己的风险，并通过使用第一封电子邮件对您通过蓝色法国号试播集的前几集发表评论，将所有后续电子邮件都扔掉，未打开。
A good portion of those episodes talked about what made him different and why the viewers who called and wrote and loved it so much.
这些剧集的很大一部分讨论了他的与众不同之处，以及为什么打电话、写信并如此喜爱它的观众。
I've recommended hymnium to many people over the years, and I always felt disappointed.
多年来我向很多人推荐了赞美诗，但我总是感到失望。
It felt important to me to convey why it was so good, and that it was good in a different way from other sitcoms we would talk about.
对我来说，传达为什么它如此出色以及它与我们谈论的其他情景喜剧不同的方式很重要。
I needed to get them to appreciate what was going on here, and I couldn't do it.
我需要让他们了解这里发生的事情，但我做不到。
Listening to how we made your mother so far is a welcome opportunity to make a more informed go at it.
到目前为止，聆听我们如何塑造你的母亲是一个很好的机会，可以让你更了解这一点。
Hymnium didn't teach me anything foundational, or get me through anything, or change the path of my life for the better.
Hymnium 没有教给我任何基础知识，也没有帮助我经历任何事情，也没有让我的人生道路变得更好。
Yet, I still think I have as deep a love and connection to the show as those listeners who called or wrote and telling you how it did those things for them.
然而，我仍然认为我对这部剧有着深深的热爱和联系，就像那些打电话或写信告诉你它是如何为他们做这些事情的听众一样。
Okay, almost as deep.
好吧，差不多一样深。
Another clue to what makes the show so special is Matt Rice's reason for his immediate and unique reaction to him, him, among your new series ideas.
这部剧如此特别的另一个线索是马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）对你的新系列创意中的他，他的立即而独特的反应的原因。
Another was the divided industry reaction as you shopped and started the show and the common threat of those who, quote, got it.
另一个原因是，当你购物并开始演出时，行业反应不一，以及那些得到它的人的共同威胁。
And then there were your observations about the audacious vulnerability of Ted's character, which we see so well written and acted in that pilot speech after he fucks it up with Robin, and Craig admitting how he felt evil casting calamities in their path.
然后是你对泰德性格中大胆脆弱的观察，我们在他与罗宾搞砸后的试播演讲中看到了这一点，他在与罗宾搞砸后的演讲中看到了如此出色的写作和表演，克雷格也承认他对在他们的道路上制造灾难感到邪恶。
Previously, I felt the closest I came to identifying what makes the show special is when I would tell people that the writers and the characters know it's all about the story.
以前，我觉得最接近确定这部剧的特别之处的时候是我告诉人们编剧和角色都知道这一切都与故事有关。
This was something my friends and I had been saying through our 20s, it's for the story, from some ill-advised and quickly hopeless adventure I wish I could remember.
这是我和我的朋友在 20 多岁的时候一直在说的话，这是为了故事，来自一些不明智且很快绝望的冒险，我希望我能记住。
Even after beefing it up into a folk philosophy, it was obviously inadequate.
即使将其强化为民间哲学之后，它显然还是不够的。
After listening to how we made your mother, here's what I think I missed.
听完我们如何造就你的母亲后，我想我错过了以下几点。
There are two kinds of storytelling.
讲故事有两种。
One is to get something.
一是为了得到一些东西。
Claps, laughs, ticket sales, ratings, clicks.
鼓掌、笑声、售票、收视率、点击。
Something that always comes down to money or celebrity.
一些事情总是归结为金钱或名人。
It's transactional.
这是交易性的。
The other is caring.
另一个是关心。
It's storytelling to people you care about as a way of caring for them.
这是向你关心的人讲故事，作为关心他们的一种方式。
You're gifting them something.
你在送他们一些东西。
Sometimes it's just respite, but usually and always if the story is nine years long, it's more than that.
有时这只是喘息的机会，但通常情况下，如果故事长达九年，那么它的意义就不止于此。
Of course, the two can overlap, but for any given story, I think it's pretty clear which is primary.
当然，两者可以重叠，但对于任何给定的故事，我认为哪个是主要的是非常清楚的。
I think him, Yum, was one of the rare sitcoms where caring storytelling was primary.
我认为他，百胜，是少有的以关爱故事讲述为主要内容的情景喜剧之一。
Then what a generous comment.
那么这是多么慷慨的评论啊。
I love that breakdown of, and you are trying to do both.
我喜欢这种崩溃，而你正试图两者兼得。
We wanted to be a hit.
我们想成为热门。
We wanted to stay on the air.
我们想继续直播。
We wanted to stay alive.
我们想活下去。
We had to think commercially, because that was them's the rules.
我们必须从商业角度思考，因为这就是他们的规则。
But I do think the deeper and more primary thing was what resonates with humans, and if that came across that, that means a lot.
但我确实认为更深层、更主要的东西是与人类产生共鸣的东西，如果能够实现这一点，那就意义重大。
Thank you for that message.
谢谢你的留言。
That means an awful lot.
这意味着很多。
That's what we were trying to do.
这就是我们试图做的。
I mean, I think one thing you'll hear from the show, from Craig, from me and from other people who were deeply involved in the making of it, we did care.
我的意思是，我认为你会从这部剧中听到一件事，从克雷格、我和其他深度参与制作的人那里，我们确实很关心。
We cared a lot, and I'm glad that That comes through, you know?
我们非常关心，我很高兴这一切得以实现，你知道吗？
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
And that's, I think that's why we're still here talking about it, it's why we're all still friends, and that is the type of art we want to hopefully still be making, and that's the spirit of this very podcast.
这就是，我认为这就是为什么我们仍然在这里谈论它，这就是为什么我们仍然是朋友，这就是我们希望仍然能够制作的艺术类型，这就是这个播客的精神。
Yeah, and I am, we are signing off in the spirit of great optimism that in an hour and 15 minutes, Craig Thomas and I will be having dinner together.
是的，我是，我们本着非常乐观的精神签署协议，一小时十五分钟后，克雷格·托马斯和我将一起吃晚饭。
I think we'll now have talked about this dinner in like four or five episodes.
我想我们现在应该用四五集的时间来讨论这顿晚餐。
This will like cover months.
这就像盖几个月一样。
People will be hearing about this into the fall.
到秋天人们都会听到这个消息。
We'll have to follow up and say how the dinner went after.
我们必须跟进并说明晚餐后的情况。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
There's a lot of pressure.
压力很大。
A post-mortem.
尸检。
What if we sit across from each other and I'm just like, I got nothing?
如果我们坐在对面，而我却说，我什么都没有怎么办？
I know, it's like we're talking all the time on a computer screen and we're just, it doesn't track carry over to real life.
我知道，这就像我们一直在电脑屏幕上交谈，但它并没有追踪到现实生活中的情况。
I'd be like, you sure?
我会说，你确定吗？
You're in person.
你是个人。
We're, it has been a minute since I've actually seen you in person, which is fucking absurd because you're 20 minutes from me.
我们，自从我真正见到你本人以来已经有一分钟了，这太荒谬了，因为你离我只有 20 分钟的路程。
Guess what, I'm coming your way.
你猜怎么着，我正朝你走来。
I'm coming to Brooklyn, that's how much I love you.
我要来布鲁克林，这就是我有多爱你。
Yeah.
是的。
All right, everybody, we love you all too.
好吧，大家，我们也爱你们。
See you soon.
再见。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，在纽约。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Appointed Blue Studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Blue Studios 指定的 Alex Reeves，我们的 Z 世代大师、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 以及副制作人 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
约翰·莫罗 (John Morrow) 的艺术作品 请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评价和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, Wherever Books Are Sold and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，事情并非如此，无论书在哪里出售，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father's Society on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的《已故父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you?
我爱你吗？
We're just New York City.
我们只是纽约市。